[Musique]
- georges est aboli aux bouches jure
solennellement que j'exécuterai
loyalement la charge de président des
états unis que j'exécuterai loyalement
la charge de président des états-unis et
que dans toute la mesure de mes moyens
et que dans toute la mesure de mes
moyens je préserverai protégerai tom
cruise et nicole kidman ont surpris tout
le monde et dit dernier en annonçant
qu'ils allaient divorcer
le couple a expliqué que leurs carrières
respectives les empêchait de vouloir et
ensemble la chute du marché a été
brutale et rapide
le nasdaq se retrouvent exemple qu'à la
clôture sous la barre des 2000 points
pour la première fois depuis plus de
deux ans le 40ème président des états
unis ronald reagan
né le 5 février 1911 a fêté son
anniversaire en petit comité dans sa
résidence de los angeles secteur
industriel a encore subi une baisse
cette semaine mais certains sont tout de
même sortis vainqueurs notamment l'ong
shark dont l'action a atteint des
hauteurs record quatre jours de suite à
wall street
dans quelques minutes nous parlerons pdg
de langue sharks top sterling mais tout
de suite
marc clip parlez nous un peu de cette
compagnie d'abord c'est une superbe
histoire que celle de l'inde sharks
on est dans une période où l'économie
industrielle est en chute libre mais
cette compagnie qui est entré en bourse
il ya quatre jours a vu la valeur de son
action grimper de 5 100 % oui c'est
inouï
nous allons parler au pdg lelangue
sharks top starring tome est ce que vous
nous entendez très bien avant tout
félicitations et merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation aujourd'hui
tout le plaisir est pour moi ma première
question nous sommes dans une période
difficile en ce moment
est-ce que lens sharks va tenir la route
encore longtemps je pense que vous
n'avez pas bien compris le problème pour
l'ong shark ne sera pas de tenir la
route ce n'est pas une voiture c'est la
route elle-même
on a déjà vu les start up comme la vôtre
avant elle ont démarré fort mais ont été
éjectés avant la fin de la période de
blocage
ce doit être très difficile à vivre ça
c'est le monde des affaires c'est ce qui
sépare les hommes des petits garçons
tout à fait tom félicitations et merci
d'être venu nous voir et d'avoir répondu
à nos questions
y'a pas de quoi quand vous voulez le
marché a donné toute confiance à la
marque mais la vraie question est que va
devenir cette compagnie dans les six
mois à venir
on sera encore là merci tu es le
meilleur
tout va bien applicable
étape
je présente
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'y serai
gfr
elle
oui mon fils
[Musique]
plus
il
[Musique]
à
je suis vraiment désolé les gars terme d
enfin on ne peut pas dire qu'il soit du
matin
[Musique]
pardon monsieur monsieur je peux vous
aider un grand la t100 crème avec deux
sucres merci le voilà
vous avez rencontré mon frère joshua le
génie action doit cette aventure brad
johnatan on se connaît depuis longtemps
vous êtes messone neuberger chanter
alors vous êtes unis sol new land shark
gagnon du blé nous attendions croyez que
vous aviez une proposition alors mais on
a du mal à se comprendre toutes mes
excuses mais je crois que comme une
monnaie qui on est la marque parle
d'elle-même à qui d'autre part les vous
qui vouliez vous voir et bien je le même
marrant ce soit le sujet de notre il n'y
a personne d'autre à voir du moins
personne d'important parce que personne
ne fait comme nous vous le savez alors
arrêtez vos conneries
si vous n'avez pas de proposition
quelque chose qu'on puisse présenter
vous savez on aura beaucoup de mal à
vous vendre à nos supérieurs
la prochaine fois on ira voir
directement vos supérieurs c'est
prétentieux venant d'une petite société
clé votre période de blocage 1 181
standard jusqu'au 14 septembre soit
quatre semaines selon la régulation du
marché va vous empêcher d'acheter et de
vendre tous vos millions ce n'est que du
vent
une seconde avant de s'énerver et à
l'est ne savez pas ce que vous voulez
n'importe qui peut vous offrir un accès
internet le moindre trou du cul dans un
fauteuil peut vous donner ça depuis le
dernier trimestre 99
mais n'importe qui n'a pas le dernier
cri beta tester et multiplateforme en
matière d'architecturé ajustable
nous si et c'est ce que tout le monde
veut vous voulez de l'internet
du pur internet pas du e-commerce ou du
e-business ce modèle là n'existera plus
dans six mois mais l'internet sans
concession sans complexe sans censure
par un g d'internet coupés avec du
laxatifs de l'internet pur jeu choix
c'est ce que c'est et je sais ce que
c'est c'est ce que fait l'homme sharks
la preuve c'est que quand l'internet
change on est déjà sur le coup
à l'affût prêts à bondir est ce que
d'autres s'y connaissent autant
non je ne crois pas sinon c'est eux que
vous appelleriez mais c'est moi c'est
moi que vous avez appelé et je sais
pourquoi parce que vous voulez en être
c'est d'accord bien alors parlons
chiffres
notre directeur financier dylan von
shaeke appelé le effet que line offre on
verra ce qu'on peut faire pour vous
[ __ ] de merde
tu as bien merdé
plus jamais est encore plus jamais tu
t'excuses devant un banquier on n'a
jamais tort
vraiment désolé
g
oh non c'est dit abhorrer là que je
passerai par la maison avant juste pour
voir si tout va bien je te conduis non
non ça va on se retrouve au bureau
quoi
tu as entendu pour pseudo - comme ils
ont lâché 60 peut-être 70%
tout le monde sait que les développeurs
c'était couru d'avancé qui appelait
choisi pau il avait deux ans tout comme
vous je n'atteindrai bon vous l'aurez
donc deux fois comme un skin quelqu'un
sur mon trône ne joue pas les papa ours
avec moi comme tu les as envoyé balader
qui pouvait pas l'en empêcher
j'ai fait comme dames mélanie moi je te
dis pas comment faire genre a rien à
faire site envoie balader toutes les
personnes qui veulent nous financiers on
a déjà ce nom marque c'est amplement
suffisant
cette insuffisance nos marques à trois
mois de retard il nous faut des entrées
d'argent rapidement si tu veut de
l'argent prend le jeu c'est qu'il
téléphoneront et orale blé ils vont
appeler dylan tu peux me croire
j'ai des milliards d'actions dans shark
sur les bras et je peux rien faire avec
encore 28 jours mélanie fin de la
période de blocage dont quatre semaines
dans quatre semaines si on n'a pas
injecté de fond on va le toucher le fond
on est repris à 12 dollars on a grimpé à
60 et la semaine dernière on était à 7
il faut savoir où on en est 2,3 alors
faut se mettre au boulot je peux avoir
mon trône
salut j'ai ton chocolat chaud tu peut
être pas celle là tu peux me donner un
bavoir oui tu sais joshua il faut que tu
m'aides à déballer les cartons j'y
arriverai pas tout seul je sais désolé
on va tout déballé ce soir premier tient
écoute chez j'ai pas le temps de rester
est ce que je peux faire quoi que ce
soit avant de repartir
l'embrasser
comment il va il va bien il s'est
endormi
tu veux te dire tu veux ton chocolat
commence à jamais par tout ce que je dis
tu ne dis pas que je ne peux pas mais
que je ne devrais pas ça n'a rien à voir
fais ce que tu veux tu vas à jane hupe
string basile pourquoi tu me demande je
veux seulement que tu me donnes les
chiffres pas que tu me fasses la morale
de la non seulement les chiffres avec la
maintenance était pilote local y avait
tout un million par mois
plus ou moins un million par mois et
combien ça me coûte de malwares g5 tu y
as pensé tu as déjà pris cela en compte
tu me regardes la cgt un prétentieux qui
fait comme si la crise de juillet ne
s'était pas produite mais elle a bien eu
lieu
abby cohen faisait des projections
élogieuses et le lendemain ainsi sur
évaluer tout ça mais qu'est ce qu'on
vous l'a dit lahm c'est quoi le rapport
avec ce que nous ont fait question
d'évaluation au top
ellison à un golf stream crise un
gulfstream ross à un gulfstream s hausse
à un golf stream cet [ __ ] de pesos
mais ne pas avoir de jets privés
ça me coûte de devoir dire au monde que
tom n'est pas des leurs et ça ça coûte
largement plus d'un million par mois un
million par mois ça sans brad être vu
comme un perdant hors de prix c'est naze
on en a qu à attendre j'avais raison
pour une histoire pas vrai ils ont
téléphoné je te l'avais dit toi et
mélanie vous devriez me faire un peu
plus confiance il te faudra plus que de
la fumée et des miroirs
si tu n'es pas la solution à l'heure tu
es le problème tu veux berrer
trouver un moyen en faisant un arbitrage
ou une fusion de crédit je m'en fous
mais tu veux que je te dise tu vas
adorer ça tu vas adorer volet dedans tu
va m'appeler et dire tom j'emmène ma
famille à hawaii dacquois gobain 3,3 tu
va emmener ta femme et tes trois gamins
hawaï et je dirai ce week-end pas de
problème prend le jet autre chose je te
prends madila qu'en ce jour viendra et
viendra
les parties ont peur
ça qu'est ce que tu fais là
et dylan savard salut sera des rentrées
depuis longtemps il ya deux semaines
environ
je vais y aller top je montre
ravi de t'avoir vu sarah à plus tard oui
ça m'a fait plaisir aussi
j'étais venu demander à qui s'ils
pouvaient me faire bosser ici comme
sérieuse alors tu compte rester oui la
fac reprend dans un mois ou est-ce que
tu habites au même endroit mon bâton
frère je sois ça va oui il va bien tant
mieux tu lui passera le bonjour d'accord
côté
m
qui c'était
tu veux faire quoi ce soir taxis
salut
[Musique]
on
un récent sondage montre que plus de 55%
des américains désapprouvent la décision
du président au jeu de brand 30 jours de
vacances si le président reprend du
service le 1er mai il le battra le
record de vacances détenue par richard
nixon
les nouvelles frasques d'une célébrité
pour les gros titres de notre journal
l'acteur ben affleck a été arrêté pour
conduite en état d'ivresse alors qu'il
rentrait d'une boîte de nuit de malines
la star va devoir suivre une cure de
désintoxication pour soigner ses
problèmes d'alcoolisme
par ailleurs nicole kidman a refusé de
répondre à nos questions au sud sont
morts sur le coup
une équipe de scientifiques est allé sur
place pour étudier le phénomène les plus
grands chercheurs de la nasa ont été
appelés à se rendre dans le désert de
l'arizona pour observer les traces de la
police notre équipe était avec eux aux
films et leurs découvertes
les images que vous allez voir sont
susceptibles heurter les âmes sensibles
et sont déconseillés aux jeunes publics
restez avec nous pour découvrir les 30
événements provoqués par l'un des plus
grands mystères de la science le gratia
plena or de l'est
salut frangin comment vas-tu de poils
tom
[Musique]
ça va et toile à matelas
ça va
ce soir oui s'il mortes de faim
qu'est ce que tu fais regard safetic
talent et déballer les cartons mais mais
c'est ce que je fais tu veux que je
commande à manger
[Musique]
et comme tu veux en envoyer une de
quelques parents qu est ce que ça faut
encore là ça pourquoi ces caisses sont
encore la bande l aube l'on se réveille
on se bouge et on se débarrasse tout ça
je veux plus les voir dunaire allez les
gars et tom scherler corinne la chaîne
musique on dirait quoi quand j'en avais
un accord j'envoie une petite alors non
c'est fini pour lui rien à [ __ ] de
nuit que danone en fait fait lui une
petite ça ira jimmy kimmel voulait
inviter à son talk show et les amis a
décliné parce que tu vas le colloque
bientôt
dylan jolie chute on a des problèmes
monsieur arrive et ça a l'air important
comment sont sans lui je sois qu'est ce
que vous vouliez me dire nos marques a
déposé le bilan
enfin pas encore mais ils l'ont annoncé
est uni sol a retiré son offre
et nous on s'en sort comment le nasdaq
était en baisse de 87 points l'ouverture
et on est en dessous à moins d'un dollar
je suis à
quelles sont mes options restrictions
budgétaires réductions d'effectifs tout
est une question d'image rumeurs les
coups bas et la peur des banquiers
peuvent nous faire couler on va
probablement devoir trouver un nouveau
financement
on a eu une offre de barton ogilvy super
génial c'est quoi larnack un autre
financier sera très exigeant il paiera
le prix fort mais il voudra être
majoritaire combien on doit lui laisser
un pourcentage dylan
quel pourcentage on devra abandonner au
final je dirais 50
joshua et moi on a lancé cette compagnie
non on a inventé cette compagnie et on
vous fait venir on vous donne des
contrats alors que nous on n'a rien et
là vous voulez laisser un gros plein de
fric nous prendre par derrière ça aurait
été plus judicieux de faire ça il ya
quatre mois dylan avant juillet les
choses ont changé on perd la moitié de
notre compagnie on se fait mettre bien
profond par ce [ __ ] de parthenay xvi
tu devrais ravaler sa fierté et hommes
non je refuse de faire ça ça ne me plaît
pas je financerai la compagnie moi même
s'il le faut t'as pas les moyens de
faire ça pas des crédits jusqu'au cou je
saurai trouver le blé tu n'a plus un
rond tire toi de mon bureau dylan
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je voulais discuter
quelque part lors du bureau
ouais
tu me laisses la balle suivante dans la
mallette de gauche vite
on a quelques soucis c'est compliqué
mais j'ai pensé à ton avenir
c'est gentil de ta part tu as toujours
été plus intelligent que moi ça pas un
souci l'envié sur ce que j'ai
l'impression des jaloux de moi
pourquoi est ce que tu me dis tout ça je
veux que tu sois dans le coup c'est une
opportunité
rien à voir avec les sharks et un truc
entre frères tom et joshua d'accord
qu'est ce que tu veux de moi tu es le
plus intelligent je suis la cigale toile
à fourmies tu as toujours été prudente
économe tu veux quoi un simple
financement de combien tu aurais besoin
exactement juste ce qu'il faut avant la
fin du blocage qu'on sorte de la
tournante quoi tu veux tu voudrais que
j'investisse mes propres et économes
[Musique]
joshua quand tu as dit j'ai pensé à ton
avenir j'aurais dû réagir parce que
quand tu dis j'ai pensé à ton avenir ce
que ça veut vraiment dire c'est comment
je peux te [ __ ] aujourd'hui c'est ça
dingue c'est parce que tu croire à bon
on dirait bien pourtant
tu sais quoi tu es un concepteur gérer
le meilleur mais là c'est du business
c'est de l'argent c'est mon truc
tu te rappelles quand c'était que toi et
moi on a emménagé ensemble la mode
street pourquoi tu me parles de ça tape
à d'autres avec notamment dit qu'il nous
fallait quinze lignes de téléphone et je
la reconnais tu es allé voir l'opérateur
on a dit que ça coûterait 120 dollars
par ligne plus un dépôt de garantie et
que ça le rendrait cinq semaines
pourquoi tu ressors cette histoire c'est
de l'islande a dit s'attendre et de
payer et moi j'y suis allé ils ont tout
installer jours suivants et gratuitement
au jeu c'est comme on nous prend
peut-être que le nasdaq baisse peut être
qu'il grimpe
mais si on arrive à tenir jusqu'au bout
du tunnel si on survit à cette foutue
période de blocage dans quelques
semaines il y a une énorme montagne de
fric qui nous attend on n'aura plus qu'à
tendre la main et à se goinfrer comme
des porcs
devant les autres je suis obligé de
donner le change
mais à toi je peux le dire sincèrement
j'ai de gros problèmes nous avons des
problèmes il faut que tu me croit quand
je te dis qu'on est dans la merde on
peut s'en sortir mais pour ça j'ai
besoin que tu m'aimes
tu dois me faire confiance
je trouve vraiment hilarant
c'est pas parce que je suis intelligente
je suis forcément débile d'hommes
[Musique]
et
je peux faire quelque chose non c'est
prêt je vais ouvrir le 20 il est déjà
une bouteille d'eau verte
c'est du bon que je t'ai ramener tu vas
adorer un montrachet grand cru 98 et tu
penses que ça m'impressionne il est très
bon papa dans ce cas tu devrais le
garder pour une occasion spéciale et on
m'a demandé de participer ou il
symposium et pour moi c'est un grand
honneur parce que c'est le plus grand
congrès d'amérique du nord sur les
nouvelles technologies et le fait que
j'ai dit est ce que tu fais exactement
dans la vie tome commence à toi land
shark
qu'est ce que vous faites davy moi je
plaisante pas j'y suis allée vendredi
dernier je t'ai pas vu oh je sais que tu
devais pas être là j'étais venu apporter
un trucage choix tu sais ce que j'ai vu
je vais te le dire des spéculoos tu me
connais comme je le dis comme je le
pense ce que j'ai vu c'est une petite
bande de jeunes brillants intelligents
qui restaient assis sur leurs chaises et
quand ils en avaient marre d'être assis
ce qui arrivait régulièrement ils
allaient à la cuisine et sans fournet
des spéculoos et ils retournaient à leur
bureau de très jolis bureau design si je
ne m'abuse pour jouer au solitaire sur
leur ordinateur
alors qu'en juin si je me trompe mais
ils doivent trouver une journée très
longue de dix heures du matin jusqu'à 10
heures du soir sept jours par semaine
mais
pourquoi diable quelqu'un irait vous
donner un million de dollars
juste pour jouer au solitaire et manger
des spéculoos pas par ajoute une poignée
de zéro ajoute 2 0 et là tu comprendra
peut-être n'est pas parce que tu
considères tu es échec comme des
réussites que tu dois voir ma réussite
et dire que c'est un échec table maman
je parle à papa je n'ai pas encore
terminé
je n'ai dira comment cette conversation
est en train de tourner j'étais en train
de parler et je n'ai pas encore terminé
tu veux entendre ce que j'ai à dire est
ce que tu veux l'entendre parce que lui
il ne veut absolument rien entendre vous
vouliez quoi vous vouliez changer le
monde
mettre fin à la guerre la poésie
accessible à tous et ça ne va pas le
nier j'ai vu les étagères de livres j'ai
grandi avec
vous avez des morceaux du mur de berlin
et cinq exemplaires de la bio demande
est là vous vouliez changer le monde et
vous êtes devenus des fonctionnaires
vous vouliez changer le monde c'est ce
qu'ont fait place tienanmen in avec le
fax rien d'autres imaginent ce qu'on
peut faire avec le web ton gala qui a
fait un séminaire sur la théorie des
médias mac luhan le village mondial
c'est ça ben c'est ce qu'on fait on se
casse le cul à le construire quand tu te
pavane le menton fier et la poitrine
gonflée et un but toi même et ensuite tu
dis à la bonne de dépoussiérer t poster
de jean luc godard je m'en vais non
maman c'est moi qui pars
ap
à chaque jour
[Musique]
alors
jospin
certes
salut vous
ça y est
j'ai comme eu maintenant
l'impression que je vous ai déjà vu
avant
je dirais que non
[Musique]
je
nantes ap
j'ai du travail
tu finis a killer
tu permets que j'attends tu fais comme
tu veux
il pourrait manger un morceau quand affi
j'ai pas d'argent
paris
ce voyage
j dray a mené 5-1 et musique
et toi allez viens sarah je tombais dans
un élan et une salade
c'est ce que tu prenais toujours le pape
à ghannouch aux olives aucun second pour
ce 3 oui il va prendre un mini simple et
de sodas sans merci merci
quoi de neuf depuis qu'on s'est vus ça
va te roule
le boulot c'est cool lors de chaque
marche bien donc ça va au travail et
comment est le reste il ya autre chose
que le travail comme envoûté par en
parle de toi barcelone hausse et c'était
merveilleux incroyable mais jean
charmont et puis toute cette culture
larchitecture tout ça était fantastique
et les corps aussi été géniaux
emplissent le plus rester jusqu'à fin
juillet comme stagiaire saura pourquoi
on a rompu
s'il te plaît tonne g/t
je travaille pour un cabinet qui
dessinaient des énormes projets de
lotissements urbain mais qui crée des
structures vraiment magnifique et il y
intègre et en plus tous les concepts
écologiques avec des matériaux durables
s'il te plaît tu que ce que tu fais ton
truc là tu es le truc tu sais très bien
ce que tu fais
[Musique]
merci pour le dîner j'étais
j'étais très content de te revoir moi
aussi je suis contente
tu m'as manqué
tom
ça va
ça
qu'est ce qu'il ya
je suis content de te revoir merci pour
le dîner on va pas en rester là
désolé
je peux pas
d'accord ce ne sont pas ces rires je
t'assure
je comprends
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
doigts
mais
vous êtes là qu'est ce que vous regardez
est ce que je peux voir
on était en train de regarder notre
écran de veille c'est très intéressant
j'adore notre logo oui oui oui on aime
tous lallouet j'en suis sûr dépôt de
bilan
vous perdez votre temps sur des peaux de
python points comme vous perdez votre
temps de travail sur ce serveur notre
capitalisation des dépenses en
financement combien de jours avant qu'on
ferme et ils disent quoi trois semaines
oh c'est du vent tout salir mettez vous
au boulot au boulot vous êtes sourd
allez allez allez
convient
la voiture est là quoi la voiture pour
le congrès
affrété par la ville
mais oubliez n'a oublié quoi elle y
symposium c'est dans une semaine
c'est cette semaine étaient optimistes
et me dire que la raison pour laquelle
tu as la tête dans le cul c'est parce
que tu as passé toute la nuit à bosser
ton discours
on
qui est
[Musique]
et
en 1997 land shark
c'était deux frères et un bureau dans un
quartier malfamé aujourd'hui c'est des
centaines d'employés dans huit villes et
une action on guette ayew noir de
nouveau en bourse en leur fille tu vas
pas sur les maintenaient indien du monde
aujourd'hui leur action par un peu
baissé mais pas normes yak pendant que
d'autres compagnies renvoient leurs
employés oui ils embauchent vous
connaissez tous celui que je vais vous
présenter monsieur dame ce permis
sans tatouage comme bonne chance
[Applaudissements]
et
merci et les algues les super génial
bonjour tout le monde on est tout le
temps invité mais on va rarement à ces
colloques mais celui ci est spéciale à
cause de bus à cause de genzyme à cause
des petits fous les petits fours et
boissons à volonté
c'est genre de truc au caviar sur des
toasts grillés
mais vous n'êtes pas venus m'écouter
parler des petits fours vous êtes là
parce que nous sommes en train
d'assister à une révolution une
révolution en matière de technologie
mais aussi et surtout une révolution
vous pouvez deviner ce que j'allais dire
c'était pas spécialement original
franchement si je vous dis ce que vous
savez déjà ce que je vais dire c'est
comme un hamster qui tourne dans sa roue
jusqu'à l'épuisement et au bout du
compte on est toujours dans la cache pas
vrai alors au lieu de ces merdes
prédigéré je préfère vous dire ce que
j'ai sur le coeur
vous savez ce que c'est le problème de
je ne sais pas comment l'appeler de
notre truc le problème c'est que je ne
sais pas ce qu'on fait est ce qu'on
essaie de rendre le monde un peu moins
pénible ou plus chiant comment notre
travail permettra-t-il de changer le
monde
mes parents avaient raison ça me fait
mal de l'admettre mais il avait raison
quand il disait que faire une demi
révolution s'est creusé sa propre tombe
vous pensez que c'est ce qu'on fait une
demi révolution ce que l'internet est
censé faire ce que le nouveau haut débit
est censé nous apporter ce que la pseudo
révolution numérique est censé nous
apporter c'est nous rendre plus libre
s'est offert plus de choix mais qu'est
ce qu'on apporte vraiment comme choix
adsl ou satellite windows ou mac
gris clair ou gris foncé gore ou bouche
payées à crédit ou bien en 3 fois sans
frais on gagne beaucoup d'argent
des tonnes d'argent on a de monstrueuses
campagne publicitaire qui vendent les
produits inutiles et encombrants de
multinationales corrompus et avides de
bénéfices on leur dit comment faire pour
pouvoir attirer un plus grand public
vous avez déjà vu le film un chien
andalou
vous savez avec le globe oculaire et la
lame de rasoir et bien plus ou moins
c'est ce qu'on fait ok d'accord je veux
bien je veux bien mais je dis la vérité
vous le savez les liens hypertextes
s'est terminée le multiplateforme c'est
dépassé et quoi que ce soit obsolète
supprimer les intermédiaires c'est d'un
autre âge les startups ont fait leur
temps le marketing n'a plus de raison
d'être
la convergence c'est devenu ringard le
système de points comme et tout ce qu'il
représente
terminé alors qu'est ce qu'il reste ce
qu'il reste c'est ce que nous faisons ce
qu'il reste ce sont ces personnes qui
sont extrêmement talentueuse dans ce
qu'elles font dans leur boulot
ces personnes ce sont vos collègues ce
sont d'incroyables concepteurs qui
écrivent un langage qui l'ont inventé
sous nos yeux moi j'en connais mon petit
frère joshua moi je sais je sais charme
et un financier enfin dans mais bonjour
je charme un financier mais geof sur
joshua hill à l'imagination je suis
capable de créer quelque chose là où la
veille il n'y avait rien du tout et ça
ça fait toute la différence
ce sera tout merci et bon déjeuner
ah bon
dom
tom nous faut que j'aille
tu bois un verre avec moi avant hier
qu'un je voudrais bien mais non marc ela
a téléphoné je dois y aller tu es sûr
j'aimerais bien oui c'est jacob et
n'arrive pas à faire c'est me l'a des
coliques le discours tu en as pensé quoi
c'était chouette chouette
c'était gentil
g
tu as réussi son coup
tu m'a un peu inquiété au début mais
bien joué
elle me disait qu'on pourrait faire
quelque chose de tranquille ce soir je
pourrais te faire à dîner et on
discuterait de tout et de rien question
[Musique]
j'étais très content de te revoir le
soir
tu n'as qu'à me rappeler quand tu as
message d'accord
et
[Musique]
tiens merci beaucoup c'est du délire
tu l'as fait bien sûr que je les fais je
pensais pas que tu le fais et pourquoi
pas c'est pas chaud croyais je croyais
que tu te moquer de moi tu plaisantes
j'adore j'aurais voulu que tu vois les
travaux l'entrepreneur m'arnaquer j'ai
pris des photos
tu avais raison pour la clause on sait
plus clair
qu'est ce que ton du ce et c'est la
première chose que j'ai dessiné qui est
vraiment concrétisé
ça c'est le tu veux du vent
j'ai préparé du lapin
n'est plus végétarienne rassure moi je
plaisante
j'ai fait du bas tu manges bien du
poisson c'est un peu hypocrite tout ça
non lui il est mignon et plein de poils
je le mange pas assez contre mes
principes
mais là je fais une exception pour
l'autre les poissons aussi ont des
sentiments tu pour m expliquer ta
logique qu'il te plaît parce que je
comprends pas là excuse moi tu as dit
quelque chose là pour parler je te
disais que tu adores elle l'a pas faire
[ __ ] je te souviens de la fois avec
moi mon frère
oui tu étais un constant là pourquoi
c'était ma faute parce que tu aurais pu
me le dire me prévenir on n'arrive pas
eu le temps n'a fait qu'une bouchée j'ai
cru que c'était du tofu je savais pas
que c'était un petit lapinous tu as dit
que tu avais jamais mangé un si bon tofu
hypocrite minable
ce
alors quoi d'autre quoi de neuf
y a que le boulot c'est tout
je dois gérer les sharks et ça se passe
bien tu es heureux ouais
justement ça doit être sympa travailler
avec ton frère non et vous avez l'air de
vous en sortir plutôt pas mal
quand j'étais en espagne au printemps
j'ai pris un train pour madrid et
quelqu'un a laissé un magazine sur son
siège
je les feuilletés il y avait un visage
en couverture je vois je déteste cette
photo j'ai l'air d'un amorti oui c'est
vrai mais j'avoue être d'accord
évidemment tu fais ta pose de beau gosse
avec tes lèvres pincées en avant j'avais
l'air top gun ce que je veux dire c'est
que cet article pour moi c'est du délire
tu as réussi toutes les nuits on en a
discuté
tu me disais qu'il n'y avait pas de
deuxième place pour ce que vous
prépariez pas de deuxième place j'ai
jamais dit ça c'est le truc le plus
ringard qui soit je dirai jamais rien
d'aussi ringard gène fait que redire ce
que tu as dit et tu es tout à fait du
genre à dire des trucs ringards
c'est ce que j'aime chez toi tu ne fais
jamais dans la demi-mesure cas réussite
je suis vraiment contente pour toi
allez dis moi s'il te plaît tu dis moi
ce que ça fait c'est pas si génial
crois moi alors dis-moi comment c'est
vraiment
les choses ont changé depuis cet article
m
il ya cinq mois un moment de l'article
je choix et moi on a
le 14 mars notre patrimoine combiné a
atteint 387 millions de dollars
mais aujourd'hui nous ne valons plus
qu'un centième de sa et land shark a
flambé 95 millions $ en amorçage ce qui
fait qu'on n'a plus aucun revenu qui
soit vraiment conséquent pour faire
simple on est foutu
mais ça fait rien on s'est bien amusé ne
parlons pas du land shark
je suis sûr que tout ira bien parle moi
de toi sur quoi tu bosses
c'est il ya une résidence c'est moi qui
vais dessiner une galerie expose ont
fait l'inauguration demain soir une
résidence
oui enfin ce n'est qu'une petite maison
ce fantastique quand est-ce que je peux
l'avoir je les fait l'an dernier pour
l'instant il n'ya climat qui étaient des
plans mais je crois que je me suis bien
débrouillé j'ai envie de l'avoir bien
demain uniquement des 17 à 19h 17h
compte sur moi
eichinger rentrer
m
[Musique]
burton au qui lui faisait des finances
avant votre naissance
à droite de parler du prix
arrivent directement
dans votre peau
fischer avait qu'un pas
vous pourrez le voir à 9 heures demain
on préférait peut-être en parler entre
vous et me rappeler prévenez ma
secrétaire avant midi comme je voulais
dit si vous n'êtes pas prêts à donner
une part majoritaire
si j'insiste c'est pour être sûr vous
avez bien compris je ne veux faire
perdre de temps à personne
nous serons là nous serons là à 9 heures
demain matin
merci
ou est ce qu'on a pour le gulf stream
je vais le voir
[Musique]
j'irai voir jeu choix
loin des bavures mon frère
rassure toi
une enseigne des manettes
[Musique]
c'est la base
c'est à peu près ce que votre truc c'est
que t'as pas vu je choisis les par là
et si tu appuies tu vois
le choix
tu peux venir
[Musique]
au tome tue le tue bien lookée ton frère
tu lui as dit que je voulais lui parler
regardez moi ce match là on dirait une
pizza mais c'est complètement absurde
la maison est de loin la meilleure se
démarque par rapport aux autres
il viendra pas plus regardées qui
viennent entre j'ai parlé trop vite
est-ce que j'ai loupé l'inauguration de
17 heures à 19 heures
je t'avais prévenu je pense que je vais
rester avec mes amis
tu m'en veux pas quand même pas du tout
c'est de ma faute j'ai cru que tu avais
peut-être changé j'espérais fais
attention à toi tu d'accord
[Musique]
vous
tiens ça il faut faire attention ils
peuvent parler et parfois il fait dans
sa couche en même temps qu'ils mangent
comment va ton frère cet homme je sais
pas
un colis express pour nous ça pèse une
tonne
tu sais ce que c'est ça vient de tom
papa vas-y ouvre la casse de la part de
vos amis de l'orgue sharks
nous vous souhaitons de trouver la voie
de la sagesse
la voie de la sagesse la sagesse
ça c'est bien
au celi tom comment ça va on allait
partir dit joshua pourquoi tu restes pas
je vais coucher jacques non non non on
devrait rentrer à la maison maintenant
je t'assure on prendra un taxi au revoir
tout le monde
au revoir au revoir nos gaillards je
retrouve à plus tard merci d'être venus
dîner
merci à vous je les accompagne jamais
d'accord alors voir g
j'ai dit des choses la dernière fois que
je suis venu j'ai dit des choses je les
ai dit avec colère et bien souvent la
colère n'est pas le moyen le plus
approprié pour s'exprimer
david je crois qu'il est cette s'excuser
qu'est ce que tu en penses
j'ai pas allumer mon décodeur alors je
suis pas sur écoute mais aussi que je
dois le dire clairement très bien je
m'excuse je suis désolé pardonnez moi je
t excuse tonnes
je sais que ça doit être dur pour toi et
je voudrais aussi dire que ton non
sérieusement c'est rien ne dit rien je
voudrais dire aussi que c'est très
gentil merci pour cette caisse pour la
caisse et pour ce qu'il y avait dedans
ravi que ça vous plaise l equel tai tak
a gardé à peu près comme ça plus ou
moins environ 50 cm pas plus grand que
ça elle ne fait pas un mètre de haut
elle ne fait pas l'être de aurait-on dit
abou dahdah exactement nancy ça n'a rien
à voir ce n'est pas ce que je veux dire
pas du tout vous êtes à côté de la
plaque
vous voyez ce que je veux dire c'est que
tom ne fait jamais cadeaux d'accord tout
le monde fait des cadeaux
tom non parce que ce serait trop naze ce
serait beaucoup trop dernier trimestre
je me trompe nord tom tom au lieu de
faire des cadeaux pour fêter la réussite
de la charte pour fêter la fin de la
période de blocage il vous donne
mais bon tome étant ce qu'il est il doit
y avoir une sorte de hiérarchie plus ou
moins logiques
comment savoir ce qui est dans le coup
si on ne sait pas ce qui est hors du
coup
vous voyez donc il y aller grand bouddha
et les petit bouddha pas vrai comme
et dites moi vous êtes qui déjà ah oui
seulement sa mère et son père rien totok
petit
faut que je rentre
je choix je te raccompagne je rentre en
taxi merci on va se promener un peu
avant
je te plait je sois
qu'est ce que tu veux
je ne veux rien
bon alors qu'est ce qu'on fait là
il fallait qu'on se promène
je veux discuter tu veux discuter
tu vas sortir des arguments et en
conclusion tu diras jeu choix tu veux
bien me transférer tes actions s'il te
plaît rien qu'une journée ou une semaine
t'as qu'à signer ce papier et tout
rentrera dans l'ordre engins c'est ça
je veux seulement discuter je sois resté
avec toi
tu comprends la position dans laquelle
tu mais je suis dans la même position
pas tout à fait
non pour toi c'est rien d'autre qu'un
jeu tu t'amuses bien mais pour moi c'est
différent je dois penser à mort est là
et à jacob
je n'ai pas les moyens de jouer j'ai un
enfant je te rappelle je viens d'acheter
un appartement
j'ai un énorme crédit à rembourser et je
me rends compte que c'est beaucoup trop
terre-à-terre pour toi mais c'est ma vie
et c'est comme ça
écoute ce que tu as dit dans son
discours oui symposium propos de moi et
à propos de mon travail c'était très
gentil j'ai été très touché mais on
avait un accord je fais ce que je dois
faire et tu fais ce que tu as à faire
eh bien j'ai fait ce que j'avais à faire
et toi je sais pas oh ça c'est sûr tu
sais très bien parlé du l'argent n'a
aucun secret pour toi tu connais le
monde des affaires sacrément mieux que
moi mais où cette année ou est ce que ça
nous a menés je t'ai fait confiance
comme ça ne marche pas je sois commence
à lunch arc ton modèle économique
ça ne marche pas de quoi est-ce que tu
parles notre compagnie n'est pas
rentable
du moins pas de la façon dont on l'avait
prévu je t'emmerde tu fait vraiment
chier
je sais ce que tu penses de moi je sois
je sais que tu crois que je profite de
toi et ton talent je sais que tu n'as
pas de respect pour moi mais alors dit
moi je veux que tu me dises comment ton
boulot ce que l'on de chaque fai
pourraient peut-être je dis bien
peut-être devenir rentable aujourd'hui
tu peux dire ce que tu veux sur moi mais
j'ai misé gros sur ton idée j'ai parié
sur toi très gros mais les prévisions de
ventes qu'on avait fait
elles ont trois ans de retard quasiment
on n'a pas encore la technologie
du coup notre marché ce n'est que du
vent si c'est rien c'est quand même pas
de marge il m'a dit ça je n'ai jamais
dit ça jeter non juste les faits la
réalité de notre situation on est pareil
que toutes les autres start up the choir
c'est un effet de mode et que penses-tu
qu'on va devenir quand la mode sera
passée c'est vrai j'ai dépensé un fric
monstre pour des conneries mais c'est ce
qui nous a fait tenir si longtemps un
écran de fumée
c'est ça que l'on sharks a voulu vendre
je pense que ton idée aura de l'avenir
dans trois ou quatre ans peut-être mais
on tiendra pas si longtemps on ne
tiendra pas trois semaines
si on n'arrive pas à trouver un
financier demain c'est foutu et pour ça
il faut que tu m'aides
j'ai besoin de la permission
je suis me touche pas
on n'était que ce soit et moi on
habitait encore celle aux parents enfin
je suis ait nos cordes
on a discuté un soir après dîner au
vieux était partie au lincoln center
on se disait que c'était possible et moi
j'insiste est on peut y arriver si on y
met du nôtre et joshua a eu comme un
déclic
il a tout compris et nos parents
n'étaient pas là pour nous dissuader il
a eu comme une vision du projet il a dit
on peut le faire alors on a loué un
bureau dans un quartier pourri mais
alors vraiment pourri avec des cafards
et des normes ras tellement énormes
qu'ils étaient plus gros que des chats
je vous promets ont préféré rencontrer
nos clients dans un restaurant jamais au
bureau parce que forcément c'était plus
quelques gorges qu'autre chose à perdre
au double
[Musique]
notre premier client il s'appelait
goldblatt il nous dit faire une offre
et je lui dis pour 1% du capital ces 75
mille dollars et il dit quand est-ce que
ça monte ou alors je le regarde sont
dégonflés sans hésiter jeudi dans deux
semaines mais ça vous en coûtera 25
mille de plus et je vais voir si les
autres veulent bien vous faire une place
bien sûr il y avait personne d'autre
vous savez pourquoi les gens s'engagent
pas parce qu'ils ont envie si on regarde
bien personne ne veut s'engager
il s'engage pour une seule raison vous
savez laquelle
pour éviter qu'un autre à brétigny
arrive avant eux et ça ah tiens v'là le
retour du babouin j'apprécie pas
beaucoup ton discours tant mieux il
n'est pas à vendre
c'est pas un peu tard pour sortir du
boulot tu fais des heures tu sais tu
veux tout savoir j'étais avec born
presqu'à tuto savoir qui c'est le
premier financier oui bien sûr je me
souviens très bien qu'en mai la presse
parlait de vous en disant ils ont
l'avantagé d'être les premiers à entrer
dans un marché de niche
seulement depuis il ya eu la crise de
juillet et on a vu que le marché
n'existe pas donc vous avez fait comme
tous les autres vous avez dit on n'est
pas dans une niche on est spécialisée
comme si ça allait vous sortir du pétrin
combien de personnes ont dit exactement
la même chose cette semaine la vague
faire c'est plus drôle de faire des
stocks de les vendre et c'est facile
surtout combien vous dépensez en un mois
comparé à au montant de vos revenus si
c'est pas indiscret tu vas fermer ta
gueule
peut-être on verra bien que le dirait
jusqu'à ce que tu le fasses ta gueule ta
gueule
ta gueule ta gueule et ta gueule
tu sais pourquoi tu es là
parce qu'on a eu un rêve
et tu as fait ce que les gars comme toi
font toujours tu as senti le pognon tu
voulais à tout prix investir pour gagner
un max de thune pas parce que c'est ton
truc ni parce que tu sais ce que tu fais
mais parce que parce qu'il fallait en
être non pire parce qu'on a toujours dit
qu'il fallait en être
tu ne sais absolument rien sur bras les
gars dans ton genre n'a aucune vision et
aucune passion vous êtes des moutons
j'ai un truc à te demander est ce que
toutes les fleurs les dîners chics
hausse et les cours de cuisine qu'il
prend arrive à compenser son incapacité
à te faire jouir
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour je lis un oeil au beurre noir
qu'est ce qui était arrivé on dirait
quelqu'un en a eu marre j'espère que
c'était pas son frère tu as parlé à je
suis allé à parler un top
ces gars sont des durs ils vont pas
tomber pour des belles paroles ça va le
faire dylan tu peux mourir
et s'il demande pour nos revenus cela je
te laisse c'est par louis symposium j'ai
voulu se peut les esprits j'ai injecté
un peu de controverse
ça fait du bien de temps en temps c'est
comme une huître qui a besoin de sable
pour faire une perle
vous pouvez me croire ça va aller
monsieur barton va vous recevoir
monsieur mobile vie est là aussi
permettez que je me au cours du 2 e
merci quelle joie de vous voir c'est un
jour à marquer d'une pierre blanche
ravi de vous rapporter je suis un homme
occupé vous vous en doutez mais quand
l'opportunité se présente enfin de
pouvoir rencontrer mes amis de nantes
sharks alors là je trouve le temps façon
de parler
laissez moi vous présenter mon associé
principal cyrus au qu'il vit cyrus voici
mademoiselle mélanie hansson
bonjour monsieur monsieur dylan kocak et
monsieur thomas sterling directrice
générale directeur des finances et
présidents nous sommes venus vous voir
pour former une association entre nous
pour que nos avenirs reste bien
distincts mais puissent porter leurs
fruits et prospère ensemble pour que
notre bonheur puisse devenir votre
bonheur notre bonheur quelle poésie
je préfère parler de notre retour sur
investissement je vous propose un
bonheur substantielle substantielle oui
très substantiel 40% à quel prix au prix
de l'action
mais les circonstances ont changé durant
ces derniers jours ne trouvez-vous pas
cette offre n'est plus d'actualité
qu'est-ce que vous étiez prêts à payer
le prix de l'action n'a pas d'importance
parce que votre capital ne se vend pas
en bourse et vous faire un acheteur si
vous voulez pouvoir vendre et vous
n'avez aucun matelas de sécurité
la vraie question c'est le conseil
d'administration nous voulons avoir le
contrôle
dites moi que c'est une blague que
savez-vous à propos d'internet
que savez vous des nouvelles
technologies que dallas vous entravé que
dalle la façon dont les gens
communiquent la façon dont les gens
pensent la nature intrinsèque du
commerce tout ça est en train de changer
ça vous fout les jetons vous ignorer ce
que c'est mais vous voulez en être
pour être tout à fait honnête monsieur
sterling nous n'aimons pas votre style
nous n'aimons pas votre manière d'agir
et de vous comporter
je sais que beaucoup d'autres se sont
laissé embobiner
mais nous n'aimons pas la façon dont
vous gérez votre entreprise et puisque
nous ne sommes pas particulièrement
pressés de faire affaire avec vous vous
devrez avoir de très bons arguments pour
nous convaincre
j'ai passé quatre ans à harvard il abat
je me suis fait des amis
ensuite walton où je m'en suis fait un
peu plus et dans les hampton où je passe
mes étés donc sans me vanter je dirais
que j'ai beaucoup d'amis et il se tourne
vers moi pour avoir mon opinion je leur
dirai que j'ai regardé vos chiffres les
chiffres de l'ong shark et que je n'y ai
vu aucun avenir
il suffira que je le glisse à l'oreille
et ils seront à quoi s'attendre me
suis-je bien fait comprendre
d'ici la fin de votre blocage vous aurez
quoi cinq cent mille actions sans valeur
des bouts de papier vous êtes prêt à
perdre votre investissement parce que
vous n'aimez pas mon style
pourquoi
parce que j'ai les moyens de le faire
c'est une menace non ce sont les
affaires c'est ce qui sépare les hommes
des petits garçons pourquoi m'avoir fait
venir vous êtes là parce que nous sommes
intéressés par l'avenir de l'en de shark
mais pas intéressé par vous l'homme
chaque n'existerait pas sans moi au
contraire
d'après nos estimations votre compagnie
ne s'en porterait que mieux
madame jim bourg va vous accompagner
attendez ne perdez pas votre temps où le
nôtre si vous permettez que je dis ça
j'ai pas une négociation monsieur
sterling c'est un ultimatum
mademoiselle hansson monsieur gottschalk
et votre frère joshua peuvent rester à
leur poste et nous ferons tout pour
maintenir le cours de l'action plus haut
vous vous démissionnerez et vous ne
céderez tout ce que vous détenez dans la
compagnie nous prendrons le contrôle du
comité d'administration et vos parts
seront rachetés pour la moitié de leur
valeur nominale
monsieur sterling c'est à prendre ou à
laisser mais il nous faut une réponse
immédiatement
mon frère je choix sera protégé par un
bon contrat de travail et des bonus en
fonction joie sterling n'aura aucun
souci à se faire
d'accord
j'accepte votre enfant
tam
je fais bien
tout va pour le mieux
attendez soumaré
il
oui
[Musique]
la chasse aux esprits sayah qui tue dans
un accident d'avion dans les bahamas
d'après nos renseignements la chanteuse
de r'n'b et aux bahamas pour le tournage
de son prochain clip
les peut avoir de la monnaie peu après
le décollage à l'aéroport international
de mashhad arbore les autorités sont
déjà sur place et tentent de déterminer
les causes de cette tragédie qui l'a 6
millions de fans en deuil partie d'un
mode
[Musique]
m
le match
[Musique]
bien joué alors j'ai
tu me laisses la minute suivante
j'en aurais pour un moment
voilà
[Musique]
on pourrait peut-être toi et moi on
pourrait peut-être
le lancer
monter quelque chose recommencer à zéro
tu sais solidarité
c'est terminé je choix
combien tu as à moi jouer celle ci non
monsieur
la manette de gauche
tu vois
jackpot
vous
il
japon
[Musique]
or elle c'était quoi ça c'est plus je
veux pas
ces montages m'a appris touchés
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]